це дорога до Херсона точніше те що від
неї залишилося протягом останніх місяців
тут тривали бої урешті російські війська
відступили не маючи змоги чинити спротив
постійним атакам ЗСУ по логістичним
маршрутам Утім перемога дісталася
Україні чи малою ціною Це село
перебувало одразу за позиціями ЗСУ тут
складно знайти в цілі будинки
ракета що застрягла в землі одна з
видимих небезпек не розірвані снаряди
міни одразу і не помітиш
дорогою до Херсона ми перетинаємо
колишню лінію фронту українські
військові прагнуть показати що вони не
стріляють по мирних жителях та їхніх
будинках на відміну від росіян тож село
Благодатне залишилося у набагато кращому
стані ніж те якими щойно залишили
донедавна тут була російська база після
стількох місяців ізоляції від
зовнішнього світу місцеві прагнуть
розповісти свої історії
кидались бігали і дома воровали обносили
заходили в любу хату виносили все що
можна все що бачили їдеш 25 І вони могли
встановити встановити
тут уже звикли жити без електрики світло
зникло в селі ще 14 березня
більшість мешканців цього села не змогли
призвичаїтися до бойових дій та життя в
окупації нині тут залишилося лише
близько чверті довоєнного населення
чоловік і жінка і в один Дом 2 його
вбило снаряд а потом через 40 днів жінку
вбило
Ой
зразу люди і виїхали але виїхати могли
не всі люди не хотіли лишати на жити
майно боялися що розграбують
кози
на кого вросиш корови на кого кинеш
Так ми подивились що вони як кажуть що
людям поробили те що повиїжджали
виводили свиней різали корову різали
теляти різали даже ночью Ми боялися
ночью щоб если у хаті
фонаричок отаку світиш і йдеш боїшся
щоби вікна одеяла вішали щоб ви не було
видно що в нас свет горить Ірина все
життя прожила у благодатному навчалася у
місцевій школі а потім працювала тут
бухгалтером комірником Під час окупації
росіяни перетворили школу на свою базу
кабінет директора використовували як
житлове приміщення
все вони тут спали во вони тут спали
вони робили що хотіли вони осьо взяли
вскрили сів в якому денег не було тут
лежали Просто наші трудові книжки
работников і просто документація останні
уроки тут проводилися 23 лютого на
шкільних дошках замість прикла у прав
тепер прощальні послання від росіян з
нецензурною лексикою і прокляттями на
адресу українців Ірина розповідає Що
росіяни до кінця вірили у власну
пропаганду одне оправдання було ми
прийшли вас освободить один вопрос У
мене був до них От кого
От кого ти меня освобождаешь я жила и
живу нормально от я не живу Сейчас пока
ты здесь Уми у мене отут коло мене коло
двору стоїш я не живу нормально До цього
я жила нормально А сейчас я не живу я
сейчас существую я жду день до вечора
проживу я його сьогодні или не приживу
куда той снаряд прилетить до мене в хату
или полетить мимо на остановку или
прилетить рядом так як прилетіло до
сусідки і згоріла в неї хата нині після
відступу росіян люди впевнені що
українська армія повернулася назавжди
Утім діти які навчалися у цих класах
поки не поспішають повертатися за даними
обласної військової адміністрації на
Херсонщині залиши відбулося менше 40%
населення аби область повернулася до
більш-менш нормального життя потрібно ще
чимало попрацювати
зараз іде повна робота з розмінування
максимально усі служби працюють у цьому
напрямку і наші військові іде снс інші
фахівці і поліцейські Усі
хто має можливість по-друге війна аж
триває вона не закінчилася у нас учора
загинули наші побратими Учора ми вже
ведемо бойові дії далі У нас уже нові
позиції у самому Херсоні теж постійно
чути що війна досі поруч надто на
узбережжі Дніпра
останніми днями росіяни регулярно
обстрілюють цивільну інфраструктуру у
місті з артилерії
день когда ушли Перший день коли пішли
вони звісно боялися стріляти мабуть а
зараз не завжди зрозуміло звідки
стріляють А в інші рази чутно що звідти
десь летить а там вибухає взривається
Там ми вже слышим вже чуємо розуміємо де
розмінування це просто вибух один Бабах
це десь розміновують в області Чутно як
звідти виліт там приліт чує мої
розуміємо коли звідси виліт а там приліт
попереду на регіон чекає непроста зима
відступаючи росіяни знищили комунальну
інфраструктуру тим не менше чимало
херсонців певні пережили окупацію не
злякаються і морозів